this is an incredibly simple setup this
question
um i'm just gonna do the first one i
think once you get the principle for the
first one then they ask you a whole
bunch of different versions
so here's what they begin with you've
got a poker hand
so you remember how many cards there are
in hand five very good
then they say oh it's also i think they
say it's a standard deck so you've got
52 cards to choose from
and part a is just asking what's the
probability
of one pair one pair so that's like
getting
that's like getting a pair of threes and
then some other random cards or a pair
of queens and a bunch of other random
cards okay
so here's the setup right now i think
the most important principle that's
really valuable for
all um
for all card type questions and then
you'll see i really hope i get to this
one as well
there are lots that are very similar to
this is that for each of the um
each of the objects i have to choose two
qualities for cards
it's i have to choose a suit and i have
to choose a value
right i think the most logical way is
just to think about one think about the
other
and you need both so you what do you do
with those you multiply it very good
okay
so once i do that um that's what this
this last question is about like
um number of hotel guests in a room okay
i think that's what it is
so it's like okay you pick a room and
then you pick
the number of people in it or it's that
kind of thing right so whenever there's
two things
consider them both independently and
then multiply right so here's what we're
going to do
first we're going to remember what is a
pair right what is a pair
a pair would be something like um the
three of hearts
and the three of diamonds okay i've only
chosen those two because i can't draw
clubs or spades
right now you've got the same value but
different suits
do you get that same value different
suits okay so what i'm going to do is
first i'm going to think about what's
the whole sample space because this is a
probability
question there are 52 cards to choose
from and i've got to pick
five of them so my sample space is just
that
okay this is all the numbers of getting
a poker hand okay there's a lot of them
then what i've got to do is this is my
denominator for sample space
all i've got to work out is the
numerator which is the number of ways to
get a pair
right that's all it's about okay so
first let's think about the pair
remember i said you've got to work out
two things you've got to work out two
things
you've got to work out a card value and
then you've got to work out suits
for those okay so how many different
card values are there in a deck of cards
there are 13 right um because there's 52
cards in total there are four suits
5214 that gives you 13. so i need to
select a card value
okay so there are
how many ways to select one card
value out of those 13.
hold on hold on stop stop how many
should i write them out
how many card values are there there are
13 of them
so i have 13 options to choose from
because i want them to be the same right
i have to pick one of them does that
make sense
so 13c wii
there are 13 c1 ways
to pick a card value okay
okay good then i need suits then i need
suits
now how many suits are there to choose
from there are four
right but you need to choose two of
those suits because
well there are two three of hearts in
there are there right um you've got to
pick two
separate ones okay so i'm going to say
there are
four c2 ways
to pick the suits
does that make sense are you with me so
far four options gotta pick two
done that's how many ways they are to
just get a pair full stop
okay then i need to work out the other
cards
okay now when i was first doing this
question with the person who asked me
right instinct at first trying to think
about the simplest way
right instinct says well i don't care
about what the other cards
are i've just got 48 left to choose from
right 48 because i don't want to i don't
want a three of a kind i don't want a
four of a kind so
for example if i've chosen the threes i
don't want to pick them again okay
so it's like i've got 48 other cards to
choose from how many do i have to pick
three so your instincts might tell you
to pick the
others that 48 c3 is the number of ways
to do that now
i'm not going to tell you why just yet
i'll tell you at the end if you do that
you'll
over count my question to you is why are
you over counting if you just select the
remaining three cards
in this way here's the way i'm going to
do it
again i'm going to pick card values and
then i'm going to pick the suits
okay so think about it think about it
i want to have how many pairs how many
pairs do i want
just one okay so therefore i've already
taken out
one of these cards right so i can't pick
the three anymore
but i've still got ace two four five six
seven et cetera i still have all those
to choose from
so i've got 12 options right and how
many cards do i have to pick again
there are three of them okay now please
note this okay
i have to pick them together because
otherwise i might get a pair out of
these
right so i've got to make sure out of my
i'm actually going to write them ace 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. jack
queen kick okay i've already taken this
guy out of the running
so he's not there okay but if i went say
for example okay i've got 12 options
left
pick the first one there are 12. pick
the second one another 12. pick the
third one
another 12 options i might actually for
instance pick an eight
twice it's totally possible right and i
don't want to do that because i only
want
one pair yes okay so there are twenty
three ways to pick the card values
plural okay
values what was the other thing i need
to pick suits
suits right so i now think okay
come back to this guy this had to be
four c two we know why the four is there
we don't why there's two there because
you can't pick the same one okay
now i'm actually going to think about
each of the cards independently
with suits why can i think about them
independently whereas with
cargos i can't
because the suits don't have anything to
do with getting a pad very good
i can pick or the remaining cards can
all be spades it doesn't have any
problems with that it's not going to
muck around with my pairs or anything
like that okay
so therefore for example just thinking
about one card
there's going to be four suits to choose
from and you've got to pick one of those
suits
right but then you look at the next card
and
there are still forces to choose from
and this card suit has no impact on the
other one these are
independent so you have to pick suits
again
second card or i should say fourth card
and then the final card
you've still got four suits to choose
from you've still got to pick one of
them
so there are four c1 cubed
ways to pick the suits
okay please please please note because
this is this looks so weird right
it's like why do i have to do these ones
together for c2 but these ones i can do
independently can you explain to me why
these guys can the suits be the same yes
they can
can these suits be the same no they
can't these affect each other
these ones do not okay does that make
sense that's why i consider these
together
and these ones i can just do them again
and again and again
that was all the work that was all the
work i've got all the pieces now
i need the pair and i need the other
cards so i'm just going to
take one two three four numbers multiply
them
they're the favorable events they're the
ones where there's a pair and the other
cards aren't going to be okay
okay so uh there we go it's going to be
13c1 times 4c2 times 12c3
times 4c1 cubed
over my sample space
okay which i have i've no idea what that
is okay
okay now remember at the beginning i
said
instinct told you to pick the other
cards you just do this this is like the
simple man's way of doing it
what's the problem with it i've tried to
highlight it
yeah yeah by accident if you like don't
don't care about these guys at all
and their values if you look at them a
little more carefully for instance do
this
right it's there's lots and lots of ways
in fact there's about 3 000
ways that you accidentally pick a pair
within there
right at least you'd hope because
otherwise you're going to be stuck with
one parent and you're going to lose that
hand
okay so therefore think carefully about
like even though all it says is one hand
lots is implied inside there okay yeah
so if it said at least one pair would we
do the 48
ah so if you said at least one pair that
relaxes the
um it relaxes the restrictions doesn't
it right it's like oh i've got more
options now i could have two pairs
kind of three pairs but you can have
more different things so then you would
go towards something like that but
i'd still think carefully about it
before i just said
yeah go ahead